The answer is this first expression
here, unless ui is positive, we can make
gamma as big as we want without
running into the constraint here.
And of these constraints, we hit the one
where this ratio is lowest first.
Setting gamma to this value makes
one of these constraints tight and
sends the corresponding
entry of xB to zero.
Remember that this equation came from
the constraint that xB be non-negative.
We can then bring dq into our basis, and
kick out the column corresponding to
the constraint that became tight.
We then want to repeat this process
over and over, getting better and
better basic feasible solutions.